I grew up in a kibbutz and even going to
university was considered quite
different because in the caboose at that
time they want you to and I don't blame
them they want you first to return
you're sure to walk in the keyboards so
they did not encourage you to do what is
called matriculation or anything else
and I felt at some stage that I want to
go to university but it was mainly for
their accomplishment without any any
clear pattern of what it will be it's I
read books I read about mercury another
but there was no connection so after the
army when I was accepted to the Technion
I met a friend in the Technion yard and
asked him what direction I should take
and he says that I have a good eyesight
and therefore I should go to chemistry
and it really for me it was really
studying and getting the highest grades
but I felt that eventually I would
figure out which direction to go so it's
not that I dreamt on solving some
problems